no that's pretty that's yeah pretty
awful and this woman's i said she said
she got two children
and so yeah sorry no go ahead she got
two children the last one was for a guy
that she had a one night stand with
because it was her birthday
and the guys walking around in the
background and i'm just saying like i
said if
i'll go back to it if women like this
are raising the next generation we are
going to be raising a society of broken
people
so what do you suggest you do about a
woman like people like that how would
you how would you
you know i think women need i think
personally feminism women's liberation
has been a detriment to society
i really do believe well there's so many
different types of feminism well i with
this this aggressive type the first wave
feminism i don't have a problem with as
a matter of fact um this aggressive type
feminism radical radical i don't need no
man menotrash
um
i don't know
i can do it all by myself
okay type feminism for me leads to women
like this thinking that they can call up
a show just have sex with a man because
she's an independent woman right she's
saying she's single she's just had a
penis inside her this morning right and
she's saying that she's single and she's
on the show but the thing is there's no
shame
yeah i think it's psychology there's no
shame you can do whatever you want and
there will be absolutely no
ramifications but that's not how life
works right yeah anyway i mean it would
be great if that were the case i think
we would all love that but that's just
not how reality works don't you think in
a similar way that's what men have been
doing for the yeah the problem is that
one time
wait can i can i hear it could i just
hear how in terms of what have been been
doing for a long time okay as in kind of
um not been doing what they've been
allowed to do and they've been cut maybe
you might be encouraged to maybe promote
or just lay out a safe space to do it to
kind of do what like do whatever they
want in that sense like if we talk about
like what we mentioned earlier like side
chicks that sort of thing it's kind of
like an accepted thing where they have a
lot less parameters around what they're
allowed to do sexually so maybe a man's
not calling into like a dating show but
he's definitely like you know having sex
with a woman and looking for the next
one yeah
the majority of men historically haven't
been doing that because most men don't
even reproduce
really yeah like most men throughout
history didn't reproduce eight thousand
eight thousands about the kids that
you're more focused on let's say 8 000
and 8 000 years ago it was 17 women to
one men that reproduced so it's more
about the kids
so no so women
women would pick the guy historically so
they could have picked a guy with worse
jeans but like women biologically you
want to get the best jeans you can to
pass under your kid
so so going back to what you said yeah
you said men have been doing it the
problem with this society and the
problem with the feminist movement is
that women think they can do the same
things that men can do and they can't
they cannot do the same things that men
can do they think they can and they
think they're good the consequences and
the ramifications are going to be the
same they're not going to be the same
and so
women use this argument all the time oh
well if men can do it we can no
okay do it and then see what happens
do it and we see what happens if you've
got a child
you know from one nightstand baby
because it was your birthday that
child's now gotta grow up with a mum
who's basically a whole
right do you know what i mean it's just
like
women of this generation need to
understand i'm not saying
i think this whole feminist movement has
made women think that they can become
the worst type of men that have ever
existed in history so there have been
really bad men in history right and men
have done really bad things this
movement has made women think oh i can
do what those bad men can do
those men are they're [ __ ] up do you
know what i mean like those are bad you
don't need to be like the bad guy but
and they also don't appreciate the good
men i mean right i mean you realize the
majority of women didn't even want to
want the right to vote because it came
with the you had to be drafted
so most if you pulled women from back
then they said i don't want that and
that's the thing women have been
protected throughout all of history i
also don't think everyone agrees with
radical feminism like that it's a very
like niche feminism and like generally
to say
no yeah the general feminism is about
choice and that you have choice to do
things that always comes with a
consequence but for me
radical is not my vibe
to me to me there's there's only one
wave of feminism like i disagree
feminism has always been about freedom
without the responsibility starting with
the right to vote it was the freedom of
voting without the responsibility of
getting drafted
i feel like you had something to say go
ahead no i'm just listening at the
moment
and eventually maybe
i don't think that was necessarily like
the root of first wave feminism though i
think that like speaking to them yep
sorry
it was started i'm sorry sorry yeah
so yeah i think that like
you know like historically when we talk
about this concept of feminism we are
looking at it in western culture first
wave being attached to that like right
to vote
but i think historically also when we
look at like
majority people of color people from
like lower more like impoverished
classes
we have these ideals around like women
who need to like
be working people who women who need to
be providing all of this other
um support systems for their community
which i think is also feminism and was
also always there
even within those like first waves can i
can i just read you something that you
you might not have known so um
feminism was started in 1848 in seneca
falls in new york the suffrages had 200
men and 100 women
in the 1800s to the 1920s they were seen
as terrorists planning assassination it
was seen as a supremacism movement i
didn't know that yeah okay okay yeah
so you don't you don't think even then
it it would have been oh yeah it was
totally extremist son okay yeah so what
what are you talking about this extreme
is now
so that's what i thought you were
talking about when you're saying the
first wave of feminism yeah well because
i feel like i guess just in like
theoretical discourse you have like
three waves and like into a fourth wave
which hasn't quite finished yet which is
what like i guess we're kind of talking
about now like the radical like fourth
wave that isn't done yet right we're
trying to like
figure out what that might be
um but i think like whatever that
radical fourth wave might be also isn't
what
the majority of women um are even like
feeling or practicing in their everyday
lives i also think that like
i think it kind of has gone the other
way a little bit in the fact that like
if you want to be a housewife it's
looked down upon i think like the value
because like we live in a capitalist
society um
you are valued by how much money you
make therefore i from i don't know if
this is true is my opinions my theory
like
in the olden days suffragettes were
usually like middle class women with
money they didn't have any
responsibilities like for example they
didn't have any value as in
their money weren't wasn't theirs and
they probably wanted ownership for it if
you're working class if you were like
bottom of the barrel like you were
working anyway you had to make money
right so suffragette was not for people
with jobs already is for women who
already wanted money because they wanted
to be valued in society they weren't
valued the same as their husband for
example
now
i think
today
it's not valued financially right
it's never been valued financially to be
a mother especially now but then you get
married like there's a lot of child
support now like you have to have a job
and be a mother being a mother is a
full-time job and you never sleep and i
think
like if women were valued in the
feminine like
typical female roles then maybe like
life would be better because i would
love to be a housewife
it's just it feels like it's not even a
it's not even an option anymore
like what the first guy could you have
been